this is gone long enough this guy spins
off weeks no calls no texts no social
media nothing
we need a new top five this week you to
think of something hey Heather
start thinking since it's Valentine's
Day this week maybe we should do a love
theme top five top five movie smooches
no okay um top five love songs no top
five Nicholas Sparks movies oh no no no
no no no Walter is nowhere to be found
we should do something different
something unique like a gaming top five
okay how about top five dating Sims you
play dating since mm not really
you know we should play doki-doki
literature club ooh okay
is that a love game yes hey listen
Valentine's Day is a cheesy manufactured
holiday that I would rather not dedicate
a whole episode to well excuse me
princess what do you think we should do
well I haven't been able to put down
breath of the wild since I started
playing it
maybe we should tackle one of Nintendo's
most famous franchises
I'm Heather Roose and I'm Anna Wade and
these are the top five Legend of Zelda
games The Legend of Zelda has been
running for over 30 years in that time
we've gotten some real gems and a few
flops it's hard not to call it one of
the most influential gaming franchises
ever this list was hard to put together
there are so many Zelda games that raise
the bar and even revolutionize the way
that we play games
so let's battle our way through the best
of the best in this legendary franchise
number five The Legend of Zelda the game
that started it all but it's not
technically the first game in the
continuity of the Zelda world
it's one of the last ones sorry it's a
bit complicated The Legend of Zelda was
released in 1986 for the NES players
control link as he tries to find the
pieces of the Triforce of wisdom to save
Princess Zelda from the evil Ganon
thirty years later and these characters
are still the focus of the games and
have become icons in the gaming world
some of my first video game related
memories involves sitting in my cousin's
basement watching him play this game it
was mesmerizing he would play while my
siblings and I would draw and consult
max it was unheard of for a game to have
such an open-ended explorable world this
was one of the first games on the NES
that used a top-down perspective rather
than a side scroll this allowed the
developers to expand the world players
were challenged to discover this
innovative fantasy setting challenged
being one of the key terms this game
barely told players where they needed to
go and what they needed to do
players could easily run into a monster
that they were not equipped to battle
making instant death almost a guarantee
this was one of the most frustrating and
wonderful things about it this game was
also one of the first NES cartridges
with a save file
could you imagine starting this game
from the beginning every time you played
admittedly The Legend of Zelda has not
held up great against the test of time
in terms of depth story and gameplay
however you have to pay it respect for
completely revolutionising games for
years to come
number 4 Majora's Mask this game was one
of the most unique installments in the
Zelda series it was darker stranger and
smaller than most majora's mask was
released in 2000 for the n64 it heavily
borrowed technically from ocarina of
time using some of the same engines and
coding this allowed the development team
to really play around with themes and
concepts the team really wanted to
examine how characters reacted to the
approaching end of the world and how
they would spend their last three days
this created a different tone to the
game something more macabre and
challenging from the light hopeful
colours too dark contrasts from angry
chickens to certain
in this game link is stuck in a parallel
universe called termina reliving the
same three days Skull Kid has stolen a
powerful artifact called Majora's Mask
it possesses Skull Kid he then causes
the moon to fall slowly towards termina
destroying it completely the eerie grin
on the literal face of the Moon still
creeps me out it definitely added a
sense of impending doom as players
replayed the days they learned new
tricks tips and secrets to stopping
Skull Kid it was a puzzle to track down
certain characters you had to learn
their schedules and needs one of the
most important elements that this game
added to the franchise was that of a
time limit players no longer could
explore the world at their leisure time
mattered it was frustrating here
rewarding
there was nothing more satisfying than
beating a boss with barely any time to
spare although it was an odd game it
still had compelling characters and a
heartfelt story with the new element of
time adding urgency and a new level of
puzzle solving it was innovative and
unique the perfect follow-up to ocarina
of time number three a Link to the Past
in 1991 Nintendo released the highly
anticipated third game at the Zelda
series there was pressure on this game
to do well after links adventure didn't
quite recapture the magic of the
original and it definitely delivered
from the moment you start the game it's
obvious that you are about to embark on
an epic journey you awake on a stormy
night to the voice of Princess Zelda you
follow your uncle to the castle where
you find him mortally wounded you take
his sword and your quest begins the
opening sequence added a level of
atmosphere and storytelling that had
been absent from the original game the
story flourishes through great pacing
and challenging dungeons this game grew
the world of Hyrule even further the
scale of the game at the time of its
release was almost unthinkable to this
day it is still considered a large and
diverse world another element about a
Link to the Past that stands out is the
graphics even playing it now leaves me
in awe of the top-notch pixel arts that
went into this game the music was also
great giving us many themes that are
used and instantly recognized as a part
of the franchise this game also gave us
one of the most iconic swords in game
history the Master Sword a Link to the
Past basically defines the formula for
Zelda games for decades to come
it is worth a playthrough even now and
has long surpassed the test of time for
me it is without a doubt the best 2d
Zelda game there is number two breath of
the wild in 2017 The Legend of Zelda
franchise came to the Nintendo switch
with a triumphant breath of the wild
this game went back to the roots of the
franchise creating a beautiful immersive
world for you as links to discover and
explore the world that the designers
have created is absolutely breathtaking
as much as it is reminiscent of the
original games it completely deviates
from the norms established in a Link to
the Past breath of the wild really and
truly sends you as link into the wild
the world is massive 12 times larger
than Twilight Princess
it focuses less on giving the players a
linear path and storyline instead it
really focuses on the environment
allowing for a more open world sandbox
field to the game this is what really
makes the game special there are endless
possibilities
I loved the cooking system that was
added I spent way too much of my time
throwing things together in a pot and
seeing what stat boosting concoction I
could come up with breath of the WoW
could easily occupy you for hundreds of
hours I can't wait to see where they
take the franchise from here
[Music]
and the number one best Legend of Zelda
game Ocarina of Time
this game was Zelda's transition into
the third dimension and while some
franchises struggled this game
flourished released in 1998 for the n64
ocarina of time once again followed link
through Hyrule as he tries to stop
Ganondorf from collecting the Triforce
this time with the added twist of
time-travel which has now become a
staple of the franchise as the title
implies link also uses an ocarina
players must learn melodies that give
them unique abilities and powers
resulting in one of the best soundtracks
in the franchise this game
revolutionized 3d gameplay adding
z-targeting better camera controls and
other context-sensitive controls it was
a beautifully built game with an
engaging world just like the
philosopher's walk temple the story is
compelling and emotional it added more
cinematic cutscenes than we had ever
seen before in a Zelda game this allowed
the game to become more immersive and
truly focus on the story I could play
this game over and over and never tire
of it I felt completely in love with it
again when it was re-released for the
3ds it is a must play for all gamers to
truly experience it for yourself
Ocarina of Time is a masterclass in
gameplay design music and story it will
always hold a special place in my heart
we want to know what you guys think
what's your favorite Legend of Zelda
game what other gaming content would you
like to see and what would you like to
see us cover next on the show leave us a
comment down below remember to keep
sharing your theories about what
happened to Walter using the where's
Walter hashtag on social media you can
find me on Twitter at Heather ruse
Instagram at a truce or twitch twitch TV
slash Heather ruse and you can find me
on Facebook as IATA Wade or everywhere
else as awesome Ayana
that's it for today we'll see you next
week thanks for watching
[Music]
explained okey-dokey literature club to
me okay so there are these three girls
and I'm sorry I really have to take this
why don't just meet me outside in a
couple minutes and we'll go grab some
lunch yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
hey are you ready where do you wanna go
to lunch what lunch oh great
let's get some sushi
you